carlson mamadiarov and carlson is going
for this knight f3 g3 again
which he's
dabbled in
i think he did it against van gaal of
course he studied the catalan and
tonight f3 g3 sometimes is meant as a
tool to transpose to some lines but
while avoiding some other lines of black
plays along
here obviously you don't have any of
these there should be four check lines
anymore since it's not a check him do it
countless times on the tour so not a
surprise to shakria and he follows suit
fianchettoing his bishop
yeah g6 is the big fashion where after
bishop g2 bishop g7 whiteface is a
choice if he castles you have to allow
e5 well if you go d4 you end up playing
one of these symmetrical greenfield
positions so g6
which i think was introduced actually by
or not introduced but
yeah
i will be very curious to see how magnus
carlsen tries to eke out a small
advantage with the white pieces
because i actually play this line myself
c4 i've started to develop a little bit
of a fondness for
because
things get a little bit exciting if they
capture and then you can go in knight a3
and
now that ways to make that boring as
well
and c4 plate okay
what about usually always write about
these things and yeah there we go again
c6 plate
that's sharper he's
offering up this pawn and
there's no easy way to regain it
after knight c3 because that's this
well-known trick knight to e5 knight to
g4
after which the pawn on d4 is on priests
so usually white would just play some
sort of gambit here as action in the
carlson game oh let's go there so d take
c he went e4 and now the araf played
bishop to g4
you could also play b5 just hanging on
to the pawn bishop g4 very direct h3
takes takes
and his idea is to strike back in the
center immediately with pawn to e5 d
takes e knight ft seven and if black was
allowed to take here it'd still be
pouring up the potential outpost for the
kraken on d3
magnus goes e6
tries to weaken
my death structure f takes e-plate
let's see what the world champion let's
see he goes bishop e3
strategically this is very complicated
why is the pawn down but it's not so
felt if this bishop could go somewhere
and f4 e5 would happen white would be in
great shape so it's a very very
sharp position actually
in this position at least
well it was very clear you can say that
i have a pair of bishops the pawn on c4
is weak and so on that here it's quite
obvious there is a lot of
compensation in that way but um
the computer moves into g2 and normal
is back thinking looks like magnus
might still be in
some sort of prep okay
so
now back to magnus and shaq whoa whoa
whoa whoa yeah they're still following
some very sensible lines knight is six
magnus could throw in queen e2 or he
could go f4 directly i guess queen two
will probably prompt b5 yeah
once again it's these questions
magnus against mama java i think queenie
two has just been played on the board so
b5 natural move well there's also once
again
computer even likes taking directly and
knight e5 but
is he is he really doing that
shah the king's indian bishop the goofel
bishop tune
and they just become legends
like simon cowell said that about
britney spears said to her what he
called britney spears one hit wonder no
he didn't call her one hit wonder he
said that that she literally has a song
saying oops i did it again
it's just wrong
so great so
and then we have this one
which looks like
yeah magnus went for this knight d5
cd queen c2
d4 should d2
rook c8 something like this yeah the
queen goes somewhere looks strategically
risky for black but apparently move by
move as they say
it's
i think he will
but
i did notice
that uh before he played this queen well
just after he played this queen b3 move
he gave a little bit of a wry smile
that kind of indicated that he went to
one place the confessional
and i think
i think he did
yeah so will he
if he wasn't going to go to a3 there's
no point in going to b3 then he could
have also
retreated but no this must be the idea
i don't know what the position is
white looks somewhat better to me but
it's still
double edged strategically if this pawn
can never
go here and be an asset or if it will
just be lost
but there's plenty of room to outplay
the opponent yeah
black position looks a little loose it
should go somewhere
just making moves but something like
this
looks quite interesting for
magnus said that bishop f4 was prep
and then i
clicked on some misclicks and it went
away
now bring it back up again he said
bishop f4 was prepped but he didn't
understand that position any better and
felt like playing
and felt like playing a move he
understood instead huh so we no longer
have to pretend yeah because because
when peter hein is here it's always this
big show like oh yeah this position i've
never seen before but it looks very very
interesting
blah blah blah well obviously all of
this is still
still known in your magnus
he went rogue with bishop d2 yeah
how dare you magnus
and uh
do we have any progress
no he's still thinking no make a move
magnus he has all the time in the world
one hour of it right yeah
and one
there's a move
well nice move
tackling the night it's the night the
night will be covered the question is
again f4 looks normal attempting to play
e5 does black allow that no
absolutely go e5 himself yes
yeah i'm not sure if i was so commitment
i really
i don't know the knight first and then
now the thing is with b4 anywhere then
the knight jumps here i thought and i
wasn't sure
that helps us
i was i was thinking of uh then playing
f4 and locking the bishop out
no he's going very comfortable
whoa
he's done it that's impressive actually
like we could see the computer likes it
but it's it's just a very interesting
decision freeing up
this guy if it gets taken why doesn't
win the pawn back directly or anything
but he's just saying
i
fed two birds with one scone i freed my
bishop and i freed my rook
and now there are targets before i know
knight a4
queen b3 or maybe
it's smart to take care first the pieces
are breathing well
h4 bishop h3 is still very much on the
agenda
interesting stuff by magnus yeah the
pawn he's going to take it exit he's a
porn grabber
things have happened things definitely
have happened
bishop g7 we've seen this e5 very
interesting pawn sacrifice by the world
champion
pawn to b4 knight a4 takes takes queen
b3 i think we looked at this and jared
was
knight c3 i do not intend to defend this
pawn
it's maybe an overstatement but at the
same time yeah what
it feels painful to differences okay
okay maybe
if queen g8 works so like this could be
but i don't see what you're doing after
27 like and uh also white can even i
liked your bishop move as well okay i
like it it looks more stable but then i
get worried about
queen g8 now
and i guess the end game we're not
winning and
now this is a threat
white should be winning this
i don't know if it's closer to a white
win or to draw but certainly
magnus will keep trying
and
ask some questions
the onslaught in the next coming moves
but will he
well his knight's not stable so he has
to
go back
right goes back just see two
it's on the edge
yeah
and those light squares are going to
start uh
looking very juicy for white it could
change that pawn down situation by
taking it
not sure if you will but
it's still still open
if you'll find a way
through mom and dad's defense
we have a move h5
no yes there should be five king h7
yeah he's gonna sit queen f8 if needed
won't be easy
if at all possible for magnus to break
this
because it's the old rule
if you're the defender
you should exchange pawns and he's done
nicely getting rid of the whole queen
side
diminishing white's winning chances
and looking at the clock times well
magnus does have something to play on
the clock times you know he has uh
17 minutes on the clock
shaq has a just a over 5.
make waiting moves that don't hang
anything and tell magnus okay
you think of a plan
i
don't know how he's going to disentangle
now
maybe he doesn't need to f6 bishop c7
bishop e7 and it doesn't matter maybe
but
i thought queen f6 knight f5 with a pawn
on h5 now it's very hard to break
because if you go f3 g4 then you're
awakening h4 and i am i thought it's
almost a
fortress kind of is this the current
position
current position is after queen c6 he's
still thinking ah okay it's down to 30
seconds
i'll speed up
uh shaq has just made a move
oh he went to b3 okay he ended b3
g6 bishop g6 oh no oh no no no he's
happy with that takes queen d6 he'll go
king at seven
and claim that uh he is in fact doing
okay
because how are you going to put and
i'll have a he's a depressor and
something like that
yeah i would suspect that it's now we
are now well under the realm of tactics
but
that that would be the logic because i
don't see why it was necessary it was
not called form
wow
well we have to see magnus's reaction to
this because it's somewhat of a
surprising roof
it is still very hard to win after that
but uh
look upon the pawn
it gives you hype as well well bishop g6
k6 queen uh
d6
king h7 i guess and then uh
bishop f6 maybe it's a place to start i
don't know how would this new wisdom
that
g h is often a draw maybe this is still
holding up he's taken on g6 yes okay
i
i mean for me it's nuts but i wouldn't
do it but anyway no but i also take a
look at uh shaq's clock situation he
doesn't have that much time did he
blunder yeah i'm thinking it's just a
blunder that he the clock took down to
20 seconds he made a move
and is there any chance with bishop
c3 in the same game i think it changes
much king e3
because f2 is defender 10 he's made a
move
he hasn't queen c6
is big queen c6 okay still fine king f7
same story he can exchange queens with
queen f3
it's just yeah if he makes that decision
to get rid of the queens
if not it's going to be rough the king
to somewhere else like king h7
no i think yeah yeah
at the very least white can repeat moves
um
but he could also probably i think
that's why he won a queen e4 and then
queen eight winning the pawn that was a
trick but he's gone quincy five he
doesn't want that end game
and now
okay well there's some questions but
apparently it's also good enough text
the pawn if the king covers it queen g5
picks it up anyway
no you have to i think you probably have
to run
okay he gives a check
yep
king runs to the edge of the board
attacking the bishop
so the king
so i guess the bishop just moves away
kenya plate
bishop should go somewhere
where should it go to this is the
this is the question
maybe fine i guess you chose a square
i like bishop c7
it's good
and
he has played it
queen
it's difficult to suggest to move queen
king runs to the corner to h3
yeah seven is also nice because this
pawn never gets
too ambitious the bishop can drop back
and stop it
i mean it does look winning yeah
definitely so the queen is
given the check king h3 i mean is there
any hope with queen being b1 you know
you just abandon your king and just
hope for the best okay
limited
tier tried d3
but surely you can pick up that pawn
with check you can take
f4
the pawn is not really going anywhere
i was also wondering you can go queen
queen c6 check and then you pick up the
d3 pawn oh also good dude
unless there's some queen c1s at the end
of everything
not messing around just takes the h5
pawn yeah d7 and queen f7 check
he wants to put his queen here first
magnus he is so good at queen and pawn
endings he realizes you know
queens work best when they're in the
center
queen c4 then you can drop the bishop
back to f
f4
no problems whatsoever and those three
pawns
on the right it's deadly
not much hope here yeah when he resigns
okay so we have a long time i'm not sure
but it comes down to the same yep we
have a decisive game
in uh the match between magnus carlson
against shakaria mama jarv and it looked
like it was all headed into a drawer
when one horrendous blunder from the
azari grand master just